Buenas tardes Nicolás aseguró hoy que
llevaba varias semanas meditando y
reflexionando sobre si debía dar
definitivamente ese paso al costado y
llegó a la conclusión de que sí de que
después de 15 años en el gobierno 8 de
ellos como ministra principal escocesa
debía dar ese paso al costado dijo que
esta decisión no tiene nada que ver con
las polémicas de las últimas semanas
pero lo cierto es que sí aunque ella no
quiera reconocerlo varias controversias
como la menciona la que mencionabas el
veto de Londres a la ley de cambio de
género había puesto y había minado su
liderazgo que había sido muy exitoso en
Escocia Pero además una controversia
enorme de las últimas semanas es que un
violador convicto luego se cambió de
género al de mujer y fue enviado a pagar
su pena a una cárcel de mujeres y ahí
siguió delinquiendo luego Nicolás en
medio de esa polémica en una entrevista
Le
si una mujer traslender una mujer
transgénero era una mujer y Nicolas
torrijol insistió dijo que sí lo que
aumentó muchísimo más esa controversia
lo cierto Es que hoy la saliente
ministra principales con César ha dicho
que ha llegado el debate sobre la
necesidad de una sociedad mucho más
inclusiva y respetuosa de los derechos
humanos de todos los sectores de la
población y lo que mucha gente se
pregunta ahora Luis es con su renuncia
en qué queda el movimiento
independentista escocés
es la pregunta del millón y que
tendremos respuesta cuando se elija al
nuevo sucesor en el futuro Nicolás
dollón como lo mencionabas se mantendrá
en el cargo hasta que se elija su
sucesor o a su sucesora hasta el momento
la posibilidad de un segundo referéndum
de independencia para salir del Reino
Unido no existe ni jurídica ni
políticamente pero veremos en el futuro
si ese nuevo líder de los nacionalistas
escoceses relevará a Nicolás con esa
posición tan ferviente que era
independizarse del Reino Unido y veremos
si era en realidad un deseo de los
nacionalistas o era una quimera de la
propia Nicolás quien hoy ha pedido que
su líder su sucesor continúe con esa
posibilidad que en el insisto en este
momento no existe de buscar la
independencia del Reino Unido